Path tracing produces physically accurate lighting but can suffer from sampling noise
and convergence artifacts, especially with limited samples or complex materials.
Reducing these artifacts improves image quality, stability, and realism without necessarily
increasing render times dramatically.
Our two primary means of reducing noise and increasing visual output is through sample
count and denoising.
Fireflies are isolated, overly bright pixels that appear as tiny white or colored specks
in a path tracing image.
They usually show up in reflections, refractions, or glossy surfaces, and flicker or sparkle
between frames.
You can think of them as render noise spikes caused by a rare but extremely high energy
light sample.
While path tracing attempts to minimize the most common sources of these effects, they
can still occur in some scenarios.
One of the most common methods for controlling the quality of path tracing is through a post-processing
volume.
Under the path tracing rollup, there are various parameters we can adjust to control the balance
between performance and visual quality.
Note, the parameters in our post-processing volume, as well as several others, can still
be controlled through CVARs.
This is a great way for us to lower the quality of path tracing for real-time editor performance
but still increase the visual quality using those CVAR parameter overrides when using
Movie Render Queue.
Speaking of Movie Render Queue, even with high sample counts, Path Tracer will always
have a bit of residual noise in the rendered frame.
By using the denoiser option in the post-processing volume, Unreal will utilize Intel's Open Image
Denoise library to remove the noise from the last sample.
The denoise option is near the bottom of the path tracing rollup within the post-processing
volume.
To enable it, simply check both boxes and it should be on.
Finally, on-screen are the current denoising algorithms implemented by Path Tracer through
various plugins within Unreal Engine.
Included in the slides are links to the various support docs that go deeper into using these
denoisers.
In the next section, we're going to cover editing some of our settings for Path Tracer.